G
IN MARK LEVIN, SYNDICATED RADIO
HOST, HOST OF LIFE, LIBERTY AND
LEVIN HERE ON FOX NEWS CHANNEL
AND THE AUTHOR OF THE NEW BOOK
"AMERICAN MARXISM" NUMBER ONE
"NEW YORK TIMES" BEST SELLER.
SOLD 400,000 COPIES IN THE FIRST
WEEK.
MARK, THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> IT'S A FLATULATE GREAT
PLEASURE, THANK YOU, MY FRIEND.
>> Bret: WE ARE COMING OUT OF
THIS PIECE FROM MIKE EMANUEL.
WE TALKED A LOT ABOUT RACE IN
THIS BOOK YOU SAY THAT'S PART OF
THE PLAN.
>> HERE'S THE THING, BRET.
THIS BOOK HAS OVER 400 END
NOTES.
PEOPLE SAY TO ME WHO ARE THESE
MARXISTS?
I HAVE STACKS AND STACKS OF
BOOKS.
I HAVE READ THEIR STUFF.
I HAVE READ WHAT THESE
PROFESSORS HAVE WRITTEN.
I READ WHAT THEY TEACH.
I READ THE NATIONAL EDUCATION
ASSOCIATION THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS.
I WILL LOOK BACK AT THE HISTORY.
I WILL GIVE YOU A PERFECT
EXAMPLE THAT IS UNBELIEVABLABLY
GOOD JOURNALISTIC PIECE THAT WAS
JUST SHOWN THAT AND THAT YOU
FOLKS AT FOX HAVE BEEN SHOWING.
HAVE YOU DUG INTO THIS DEEPLY.
HAVE YOU DONE SOMETHING NOBODY
ELSE DOES.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE BACKGROUND
OF CRITICAL RACE THEORY, THIS
COMES OUT OF CRITICAL THEORY.
WHERE DOES THAT COME FROM?
IT COMES FROM THE SCHOOL
FRANKLIN SCHOOL OUT OF BERLIN.
A GROUP OF MARXISTS.
ONE OF THE GENTLEMAN FLED
HITLER, CAME TO THE UNITED
STATES.
HE BECAME A VERY PROMINENT
PROFESSOR HIS NAME IS HERBERT
MACSE.
HE WAS THE FOUNDING FATHER OF
THE CRITICAL THEORY.
CRITICAL THEORY LEFT WEATHER
UNDERGROUND SDS AND ALL THE
REST.
THEN YOU HAVE A GENTLEMAN
DERRICK BELL HARVARD LAW SCHOOL.
HE TAKES THIS IDEA, WHICH I WILL
GET TO QUICKLY, AND HE
RACIALIZES IT AND THOMAS SOL HAD
WRITTEN ABOUT HIM OVER THE YEARS
AND SAID THE GUY WAS A COOK.
IT'S A FRINGE IDEOLOGY.
CRITICAL RACE THEORY JUST TO PUT
IT IN PLAIN ENGLISH IS BASICALLY
LOUIS FARRAKHAN DRESSED UP AS
SCHOLARSHIP.
THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
HATE AMERICA, ANTI-SEMITIC.
ANTIWHITE.
AND SO WE TRY PUT SOME KIND OF
HISTORICAL PERSPECTIVE ON IT THE
PERSPECTIVE IS THAT ANYTHING
WHITE IS BAD BECAUSE THAT'S THE
DOMINANT CULTURE.
YOU DEHUMANIZE PEOPLE.
YOU DON'T TREAT THEM AS
INDIVIDUALS.
IT IS A MARXIST IDEOLOGY,
BROUGHT HERE OUT OF BERLIN,
BECAUSE THEY WANT THIS:  YOU
HAVE TO HAVE CLASSES.
YOU NEED TO HAVE OPPRESSORS AND
OPPRESSED.
THE IDEA THAT THIS GOT INTO OUR
CLASSROOMS AND MANY PARENTS
FOUND OUT ABOUT IT BECAUSE OF
THE PANDEMIC, THEY ARE WATCHING
THEIR SCREEN, THEY ARE WATCHING
WHAT THEIR CHILDREN ARE BEING
TAUGHT AND THEY ARE GOING WHAT
IN THE WORLD IS GOING ON HERE?
THAT IS WHAT IS GOING ON.
KENDI AND OTHERS WHO HAVE
WRITTEN THESE MASSIVELY POPULAR
BOOKS ABOUT IT.
THEY DIDN'T INVENT THIS
IDEOLOGY.
THIS IDEOLOGY WAS INVENTED HALF
A CENTURY AGO.
AND THE IDEA THAT IT'S IN OUR
SCHOOLS IS UNBELIEVABLE.
>> Bret: NOW, I READ THE BOOK.
YOU MAKE SOME REALLY INTERESTING
POINTS.
BUT, FROM THE OTHER SIDE, THE
PUSHBACK WOULD BE THAT YOU ARE
GOING TOO FAR.
THAT YOU ARE LABELING TOO MANY
PEOPLE MARXISTS.
AND THAT THIS IS NOT BEHIND WHAT
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
TRYING TO DO WHEN YOU HEAR THAT
FROM SOMEBODY WHO WANTS THE GIVE
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION THE
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT I ASK THEM
WHAT THEY HAVE READ.
I CAN CITE DOZENS AND DOZENS OF
PEOPLE.
I CAN SHOW YOU DOZENS AND DOZENS
OF PROFESSORS, HUNDREDS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
CAN I SHOW YOU BLACK LIVES
MATTER AND THE LEADERSHIP WHICH
PROUDLY SAYS THEY ARE
DOCTRINAIRE MARXISTS.
I CAN SHOW YOU BOOK AFTER BOOK
AFTER BOOK AFTER BOOK ONE AFTER
ANOTHER AFTER ANOTHER THAT CAN
IN OUR CLASSROOMS.
THAT ARE IN THE CULTURE RIGHT
NOW.
AND THIS IS THE THING.
I DON'T GO AROUND CALLING
EVERYBODY MARXISTS.
I SAY THIS IS AN AMERICAN
MARXIST.
THESE MOVEMENTS THAT ARE TAKEN
FROM THESE VARIOUS SCHOLARS AND
VARIOUS MOVEMENTS, MANY OF THEM
IN EUROPE, AND IT'S NOT JUST
CRITICAL RACE THEORY.
WELL, WHAT IS IT?
WHAT IS IT WHEN YOU ARE TEACHING
TO DESTROY OUR MONUMENTS, TO
DESTROY OUR BOOKS, TO DESTROY
OUR HISTORY TO PUSH A RACIST
IDEOLOGY, YOU TALK ABOUT TAKING
DOWN THE ECONOMIC SYSTEM.
PUTTING RIOTING IN THE STREETS.
WHEN PEOPLE SELF-IDENTIFY AS
MARXISTS.
WHAT AM I SUPPOSED TO CALL THEM
THE BOY SCOUTS AND GIRL SCOUTS?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Bret: AT THE END OF THE
PECULIAR YOU HAD YOUR OWN
PRESCRIPTIONS ABOUT THE WAY
FORWARD.
BASICALLY THE MESSAGE IS THAT
YOU HAVE TO NOT LET THIS GO TOO
FAR AND TAKE BACK THE COUNTRY,
IS THAT FAIR?
>> YEAH.
MY MESSAGE IS THAT PEOPLE WHO
LOVE THIS COUNTRY, I DON'T CARE
WHAT COLOR YOU ARE, WHAT
RELIGION YOU ARE, WHAT KIND OF
SEX YOU PRACTICE.
I DON'T CARE.
LET'S PUT SOME OF OUR
DIFFERENCES ASIDE AND LET US
TAKE ON THE PEOPLE WHO DON'T IN
LEGITIMATE WAYS.
WAYS THAT AMERICA SUPPORTS.
ONE INSTITUTION AFTER ANOTHER.
BECAUSE THEY'RE BEING DEVOURED.
THE CHILDREN, ELEMENTARY SCHOOL,
THE BORDERS, THE ATTACK ON OUR
ECONOMIC SYSTEM, THIS DEGROWTH
MOVEMENT DRESSED UP AS CLIMATE
CHANGE, YES, AND THERE ARE MANY
IDEAS IN THE BACK OF THE BOOK,
LINKS GROUP, RED BLOODED
AMERICANS WHO CARE ABOUT THIS
COUNTRY, IT'S TIME TO PUSH BACK.
>> Bret: THE BOOK IS AMERICAN
MARXISM.
MARK, WE APPRECIATE YOU COMING
ON AND CONGRATS.
>> THANK YOU